[Music]
the nation of CHOP is nearly a week old
now and yet still surprisingly little is
known about chop for my Nonna's chas is
the nation peaceful or is it dangerous
is it prosperous is it impoverished is
it friendly is it hostile like a North
Korea on Puget Sound we can only guess
snippets of information leaked out
supplemented by daring acts of
investigation we have one such for a
tonight our own Kyle Rothenberg ventured
in to the nation formerly known as
downtown Seattle here's what he found
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so there it is documentary evidence of
life inside chop chop a staining is
going about their business choppa
standing customs in action we should
warn you though what she just saw is
just a snapshot the nation of chop is
dynamic it's changing even as we watch
for one thing it's getting smaller
nobody was small smaller than the
Vatican but today chop was partitioned
by the City of Seattle it seated several
blocks back to its former overlords in
return the country's makeshift barriers
are being replaced with solid concrete
blocks because nothing makes the country
more quickly than a border that's what
we've learned from the chop radio host
Jason Rance is our man on the ground
outside the nation of chop on the DMZ he
joins us tonight Jason I see that
they've beefed up their border security
they have although the city has decided
to beef up the border security not
necessarily those who are living within
chop so earlier today the mayor of
Seattle Jenny Durkin made the
announcement that essentially they came
to some kind of compromise this was a
Tip O'Neill Ronald Reagan type of
situation where they decided to cede
over some of the land so that emergency
vehicles and people actually live there
and drive there can actually get through
because remember chop happens to be in
the middle of a space that a lot of
people live and a lot of people work
however because we're dealing with a
organization that isn't really an
organization there's just a lot of
different people who are going into the
area for their activism there's not
really one leader so the compromise
towards the last hour or so has started
to break up a little bit there's some
folks who are angry that they've given
up a little bit too much we're hearing
rumors that there's going to be another
march towards West Precinct which is
about a 10-minute walk from where they
currently are this would be another
police station that presumably they'd
like to either take over at least use to
get their activism out there so consider
this manifest destiny of some kind they
potentially will be on the move and
maybe get up some more land fascinating
if only Margaret Mead were here to study
the Chiapas danny's and their culture
there if their famously carefree people
its I want to ask you a sort of
open-ended question I you're not
administering blood tests of course but
your best estimate what percentage of
the choppa standing people are sober at
any given time
well I don't even know how to begin
I mean we're not just talking about
alcohol correct we're talking about no
yeah no so there's definitely a
population
I wouldn't it not everybody there is
going to be high or drunk at the same
time it'll be fair to them but there is
definitely a high percentage of folks
who are kind of just carefree and having
a good time and actually that's where
some of the anger has come from some of
the activists who are there because
they're trying to change policy that
they've got a lot of people essentially
just showing up for a party that they're
treating this as a tourist destination
so yeah they're showing up hi they're
hanging out at Cal Anderson Park they're
eating sandwiches and granola and
they're having a good old time when
other people are saying hey and it's
primarily white people who are doing
this like could you maybe get back to
the whole activism thing that we're here
for so there's some inner there's some
inner struggles you know there's there's
it's always rippling beneath the surface
and parents one thing every every Chapa
Stanny has in common no job pretty great
Jason good to see you tonight thank you
good to see you